Wesley welcome to St Louis welcome for
granch tour I was wondering if it's the
city you have been traveling the most
except your hometown in your life yeah
for sure uh St Louis is like our second
home it's only an hour away from where I
live Minnesota uh you know I was living
here before and you know I would
definitely consider moving here except
my family has a job Minnesota but uh
there are a ton of grand Masters living
here in Missouri so it attracts Grand
masters from all around the
world and uh I definitely am very
excited coming back here every time
because I know a lot people a lot of
people here and uh you know I'm kind of
in good relationships with everyone here
and it's the home of chess in the US I
was expecting to see you in a of man not
that I was there but I mean one of I
thought you would try to fight fight for
the spot in the candidates but now now I
understood your approach a little bit
more yeah for also I think as a if
you're like a professional player you
have to on any sport I think you have to
spend at least half your time training
and resting and then have the time
playing so let's say in 2021 it was a
very successful year for you in GCT as
well as 2022 where you were second at
the end let's say what can be let's say
the goal kind of a goal for this one you
said to qualify but let's say speaking
about your chances now real chances in
the tour um what what what exactly you
need to do how well you should play in
both events well I think if I finish on
the upper half on both events then I
should be in a good spot to at least
secure third place I think and then
someone just keeps winning it
all because I think uh Maxim is doing
well Fab is doing well okay Fabby will
probably win leading yes let's say yeah
Fabby will probably win the grand chest
T it seems like with his current form
and also his number one spot but the
next the second and third spots are
really up for grabs uh what do you think
let's say about the prospects of grand
CH tour I mean especially now that it's
10 year university m sing cup as well
let's say do you think it's going to
happen we have this same event in 10
years and who do you think will play
from the new generation there yeah for
sure I I mean I hope it will still be
around 10 years from now uh but uh it's
uh not up to me obviously need private
sponsors for that that's why I'm very
grateful to Rex and Genie because
they've done so much not only for me but
for us chess and also many other chess
players in
in general and uh it's not so easy to
find corporate sponsors for for chess so
you can't have to rely on private people
and other people are afficionados but uh
I hope Grand store will will still be
around but it's uh 10 years is a long
time really let's see what will happen
in 10 years hopefully and all the best
of luck for you westling in the
tournament thank you yeah I really need
that
[Music]